what about um on the label side have you
because are you still independent yeah i
got a distribution deal with create
music child to create they distribute a
bunch of people [ __ ] yeah but then
you're fully that for people who don't
know
that's he's independent um
[Music]
what about signing is that something
that you've gotten close to doing or is
that something you can like you would
consider doing because i'm sure that
the labels have called multiple layers
um from coochie man
um qc was from the time you once upon a
time
i don't remember epic atlanta i'll put
me with atlanta probably like last week
a couple days ago or something like that
a lot of labels though but
that made sense to me what was the
closest cause gucci i mean gucci's i
always say gucci's probably the greatest
hip-hop a r of all time yeah uh
did you like how serious were you when
it came to maybe getting with with gucci
or qc i want to sign a goodie so bad bro
but it's just
not to put the prices out there i just
couldn't sign for a hundred thousand all
right that's not
a hundred thousand what's the deal yeah
hundred thousand and i'm like i got that
times [ __ ] in my bank account
you know what i'm saying all right and
jury i'm plus
and i'm like yeah it was a respectful
decline yeah
but i still assigned something but it
just gotta make sense
a lot more sense or even if we do like
a collab or
feature or whatever one-off album or
something you know what i'm saying like
it just gotta make sense but as far as a
full-on artist deal with me signing to
you for a honey hell nah nah that's
crazy yeah no i would tell you don't
sign anywhere for less than a million
dollars because you're making
you're making my royalty to someone no
i'm saying you're making good money
off of what you're doing right now yeah
and
you're you're owning everything you own
the master [ __ ] with pqc um but this one
what the [ __ ] you see i was dead broke
like and he tried to give me 150k
in my face and i was like damn i'm just
saying just thinking like for
[ __ ]
it went through and um i was talking to
the like people i was working with like
my management but end up not like going
all the way through
so you almost did that one yeah i almost
i was close to doing it but then at the
end it was like nah wow yeah i mean that
takes a lot to uh
pass up on on monday like that i mean
and know yourself words a lot of artists
i think that that whole entire
record industry is based on
big companies taking advantage
of starving artists and then nowadays
though
i don't know if it's just i'm pretty
sure everybody see it but it's like
every time i get on instagram i see
artists complaining about their label
like oh don't sign this meal young i
mean everybody and by the way we're
talking about atlantic in both cases so
it's probably better
i didn't know that but i'll just be
seeing that [ __ ] down there like every
[ __ ] other day there's somebody
complaining about that label that's it's
scary bro no it's scary because once you
sign
you can't say i want to put this out
tomorrow
it's like nah we got to sign off on it
and then guess what
uh your budget is this you got to pay
this i mean it's a shitty loan is what
it is
it's a high interest loan so like if you
would have taken that i don't know the
details of the deal but if you would
have taken that hundred thousand from
gucci
you would have probably had to have made
a million back off of that hundred for
you to start seeing money again exactly
so you would have had to have made that
hundred last for a while and that's
that's the advanced game and most most
big artists that we're talking about you
talking about meek mill
yg's been very vocal about what's
alfredo being say something about def
jam right so what though
the reason why these guys are so mad is
because
every time they drop an album they get
an advance check
and that's the last money they see from
that album because they make it so hard
for you to recoup
that
million dollars every time you turn in
your album
that you got to make that stretch or you
got to get them that show money or you
got to get that endorsement money or you
got to get your features right because
unless your album
is
inc like rotty rich diamond you know
like some [ __ ] like that you're probably
never going to see any money off that
album
and so that's why you see all these huge
artists saying [ __ ] the labels but at
but at the same time they sign those
deals and they and they gladly pick up
that advance check when they turn that
album in
what they could do is say
keep the advance take the album and i
just want to get paid my monthly
royalties off the album yeah
exactly
it's the short it's it's the long play
not the short night you know what i'm
saying yeah so when artists get angry
and uh
i don't feel bad because i'm like yo you
you son like
some of these dudes are grown-ass man
but some artists really don't know i
feel like if you were young and you were
super vulnerable and you got signed that
way that's one thing but some of the
artists we're talking about in the game
they know have resigned many times and
it's like you know this [ __ ] so like you
you know what you signed up for like you
signed the [ __ ] paperwork you got the
best lawyers in the [ __ ] music
industry like they
get something yeah that was a problem
too i ain't gonna have lawyers like that
you gotta have a lawyer to pay so i'm
like i need to play with myself and
don't let them be like yo we know a good
lawyer gotta look yeah because then
they're gonna [ __ ] you
get your own lawyer
and yeah not keep running up the bag
independently when the right situation
crosses your table you'll know bro keep
ownership on your masters
don't sign no [ __ ]
whole ass split because these fools will
definitely try to get you to take
seven percent of your music
they want to take your catalog they
wanna and they're like oh by the way
that independent catalog that create
we'd like to bring it over here to
atlantic and we wanna own it yeah would
you ever sign to like somewhere like an
empire
because empire is a distro situation
yeah i think i own they sent me like a
distribution deal or something like that
to start off but
if it made sense yeah it just got to
make sense to me but i can't just be out
here just no i'm saying if i bring i i
know what i bring to the table i know
what my numbers do of course apple the
spotify to youtube i know what i do so
it for me to just give up some of my
royalties and my you know some masters
and this and that it got to make a lot
of sense for you